i'm in cyprus and i have to drive on the
left side of the road right now
wait why are you guys leaving two people
mcdonald's ice cream machine is always
broken
welcome to the vlog dude i'm vlogging
today what are you posting this on uh
it's called youtube.com oh so it's like
this like platform for like video cloud
based sharing of
high quality video content they even do
hd
how do you share clouds so it's really
well it's like an hd thing so that's
like tv or something so mcdonald's is
being investigated by the ftc and i'm
here in cyprus making a documentary
series for the first time in a while
[Music]
and i want to show you some of it and i
just need to give you a bit of an update
on mcdonald's and all the things
happening right
[Music]
now remains the tinderbox that could set
off a full-scale war unless the
differences between greek and turk can
be resolved
i'm making an and like an announcement
video yeah the little video on your
youtube channel yeah my little youtube
channel i'm also vlogging
wait what is going on you're also
vlogging today
[Music]
that's cool let's just bring your cat
with us
these donkeys don't belong to anyone
i'm going to jump off a cliff i gotta
vlog it for my video
so today's video is not going to be an
explainer i know you come to this
channel to learn things you'll learn a
little bit about the lawsuit in the ftc
investigation but today i want to give
you just an update and tell you a little
bit more about the series i'm doing
before we get into that i want to thank
today's sponsor who is better help i've
said this before i'm a big believer in
therapy i believe that therapy needs to
be normalized and it needs to be way
more accessible and way more common for
people i started doing therapy with a
licensed professional therapist almost
two years ago and it has changed my life
it is not a crisis line it is a place
where you can go to find a good
therapist finding a good therapist is
kind of hard especially when you only
have the options in your city betterhelp
is an online thing it's remote you can
browse thousands of therapists and
choose one and then if you don't really
fit with the therapist which is a very
common thing you can easily switch to
another one for free no like calling
your insurance and figuring out who's in
network and that whole debacle that is
just sort of when you are already
looking for therapy you don't want to be
like
stressing out about finding a therapist
it's super easy to sign up within 48
hours you could be talking to a
professional i really believe in therapy
and believe that better help is doing a
good job trying to make therapy more
accessible so there's a link in my
description betterhelp.com johnny harris
when you click that link it helps
support this channel but it also gives
you 10 off your first month of better
help you can try it out and see if it
works for you thank you better help for
supporting this channel and for
supporting the journalism i'm doing here
in cyprus
now let's get to the update
there you go yes
there we go okay
[Music]
first off mcdonald's holy smokes so i
made this video about the ice cream
machines can i get an ice cream cone the
ice cream machine is broken ice cream
machine is broken kind of sounds like
there's a story behind that one doesn't
it this was like back in the spring and
i didn't think this video was it was a
30 minute video about ice cream machines
and suddenly there's like 8 million
views or something like people clearly
wanted to learn about this
it made a pretty big splash
and then
it turns out according to the wall
street journal who just reported on this
the ftc is now investigating this issue
the ice cream machine makers to see if
there's something weird going on i think
there's something weird going on at
least that's what the evidence points to
i don't know what weirdness is going on
but something weird is going on and it's
not just a four hour cleaning cycle
so i'm gonna keep my eye on this
the wall street journal seems to be like
really into reporting on these ice cream
machine makers like me and the wall
street journal are like in lock step
right now
and
and so i'm going to keep my eye on this
reporting and see what happens next
meanwhile if you remember from the ice
cream machine story there is that
startup called kitsch that is the one
that sort of got blackballed by
mcdonald's when they tried to invent a
fix for the ice cream machine makers
they have filed the lawsuit and they
even got awarded a restraining order
because they have alleged and have very
good evidence for the fact that
mcdonald's and taylor and this whole
cadre of ice cream machine people have
gotten a hold of their technology and
are using it to basically make the same
thing for themselves
which is a big no-no you don't do that
so this is still a developing thing but
the fact is that like i think i stepped
into a can of worms that i didn't know
was going to be a big deal and i think
the video that i made may have had some
effect on all this which is sort of a
weird thing um
wired also put out a really solid
article on this that i'll link in the
description overall it feels good to be
doing youtube but also feel like i'm
doing real journalism and that it's
being validated on a bigger scale
cool you know i left vox and felt a
little bit insecure about the fact that
like i'm leaving a journalistic
institution like
what does that mean for me and my
reputation as a storyteller and a
journalist and part of me likes this
freedom and this ability to be more
creative and more personal and like be
able to talk to you like i'm doing right
now but part of me also feels a sense of
like i still want to be like in the
journalism world which i guess gets to a
second little update which is a video
that i made with the new york times last
year got nominated for an emmy which is
like okay
that's cool the emmys are sort of like
an old legacy thing like for like legacy
tv but more and more they're they're
updated and recognizing work that is
being done now on this platform and
that's kind of exciting i'm actually
working on another piece with the new
york times right now that will publish
in the fall so keep an eye out for that
man so many updates
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
cyprus
let me tell you about what i'm doing
here in cyprus
man this is this is probably the most
exciting thing i have to say
um
where to start
on my way over to cyprus
me is and the boys stopped by sicily and
have a sort of before back to school
vacation all together first time
i was able to practice my italian though
boy oh boy is the italian and sicily not
italian
it's literally a different language but
even the italian they speak is like man
that was hard it was really hard
but boy is the food good
sicily is a very wild place
and
and while there there was some very
stressful stuff that came up there was
like a bunch of eu announcements about
the borders being closed we were up late
talking to vcs and founders about bright
trip which is a huge thing in my life
right now that i'm just not going to go
into but like bright trip is growing and
we're trying to raise a bunch of money
and like it's actually really hard to do
entrepreneurial things i've decided like
it's actually like not easy to do it
which is why like most people don't do
it and i see now why people just sort of
flake out on it after a while because
it's really hard and emotional to try to
build a startup but but it's it's
happening it's working we're building
bright trip and it's turning into a
pretty cool thing but anyway it was a
wonderful time with the kids out on the
road again after many years of not being
on the road and then izzy and the boys
flew back to washington dc and i flew
here
[Music]
so this is probably why most of you
clicked on this video maybe you care
about ice cream machine makers maybe you
care about my emmy nomination but i'm
pretty sure most of you care about like
the documentary explainer work that i do
and
the good news is that i'm doing it i'm
back i'm back on the road i'm doing it
i'm back baby the past year my life has
been very strange
vox borders was cancelled uh last year
sort of around this time and that's when
i really decided that i needed to build
this channel so i started making a bunch
of videos tons and tons and tons of
videos that you've been seeing i've been
in the office making videos but i need
to tell you that my heart my heart is
here it's out here it's me on the road
talking to people looking at complicated
stuff trying to understand it pouring
over maps and documents and looking at
archive like that is where my heart is
and i haven't been able to do that since
since borders was canceled mainly
because
this channel wasn't big enough to
financially support that and
covet 19. but both of those things have
changed this channel has grown
significantly thanks to all of you being
here and kova 19 is
kind of going away
bye-bye
bye-bye bye
bye bye hey you live here in pittsburgh
no it's not let's be honest it's not
going away like we thought it was i
thought it was so there was this one day
izzy and i were driving in iceland the
boys were asleep and we were thinking it
was like two in the morning it was like
light outside beautiful
and
we were talking izzy was talking about
like well what do you miss about
about
you know vox and i said well i miss my
colleagues i miss like hanging out with
people that i that inspire me and then i
said i miss being out on the road
and she's like
dude
go
like go out on the road like like you
can do that now on your channel and it
just hit me and i was like
i knew at some point i was gonna do it
but like
now's the time so then the question was
what story do i tell what place do i go
and
cyprus
has been on my mind since 2014. i
studied peace and conflict resolution of
my master's degree and i took an entire
course about conflict resolution and
mediation and cyprus the conflict here
in cyprus was the subject of that course
in fact that course in addition to my
experience in tijuana and so many other
experiences like that
are what woke me up to my obsession and
interest in divisions and lines and maps
so we spent a couple of months just
diving deep into cyprus and then we came
here i came here with jack my assistant
producer and this guy corey pop i've
never traveled with a real camera person
before so to have corey pop who is a dp
that worked on explained and is just
incredibly good at what he does to have
him with me to help tell this story was
a really special moment so for the past
10 days we've been on the road
traversing this entire island talking to
military going on military vessels going
into buffer zones talking to the un it
has been a deep dive in reporting on
cyprus and i am so excited to share
these stories with you
and while i was here i met up with these
guys
i invited thomas and nathaniel to come
with me to cyprus because mainly because
i just wanted to hang out with my
friends like these are friends of mine
that i've made on the internet that i
talk to
often but like don't get to hang out
with very often it's like and overall it
was just a good time to reflect and to
bond and to have some like social
interaction for the first time in a
really long time and
get this guy a spritz no
why is there a phone coming to our clip
and now they're gone and i am still here
reporting in cyprus
the stories that you're gonna see me
tell in this new series which is called
by the way uncharted that's the name of
the series
the stories you're going to see me tell
are going to feel like me they're going
to feel like videos i've always made
after all i can't
change that it sort of comes from my
curiosity comes from my voice but
they're going to feel different
they're going to feel more intentional
they're going to feel more visually rich
they're going to feel more human i hope
talked to a lot more people than i've
ever talked to i was able to focus on
the interviews because i had a camera
person you know corey was there shooting
and so i wasn't there fiddling with
audio and
and and getting the frame right it was
actually like just focused on the
conversations and hopefully they'll be
just better reported more sensitive more
clear more informative than anything
i've ever done
i've grown up as a storyteller
in over the past year and a half
and
i'm really excited to share this story
with you a story that has been on my
mind
since since i sat in that classroom in
grad school and i was like someday i
will tell this story
and i've been working with my composer
tom fox who has created an entire custom
score for cypress it's like synthy and
orchestral and minimal but also like
very intense and emotional you're
listening to a little bit of it right
now
[Music]
so i probably shouldn't like be giving
away all the
juicy stuff of this series but i just
can't help it there's too much good
stuff so let me just give you a little
nugget of what i've been seeing over the
past 10 days
for the past several decades
this has just been no man's land
there was commerce there was
an economy there was trade this place
was thriving
and then it just collapsed
so that's it that's my update everyone
it feels really good to be back on the
road i am exhausted my brain is still in
this like middle ground where i'm still
trying to like make the stories like
come together there's still so much
reconciling i have to do in the script
but i feel good i feel good to be here
back in my natural habitat on the road
telling stories talking to people
traversing a new place and trying to
understand it and trying to translate it
to a bigger audience so that you can
catch a glimpse of what's happening here
and the emotions and the people and the
politics at stake
that is my goal
that is the update thank you all for
being here and i will see you
very soon
as i kick off uncharted
you